[Music]
I'm buck Ferguson tonight's episode
isn't just about killing white-tailed
deer it's also about family hey buck
I'll go get him make yourself at home
myself at all ready to go kill your
first whitetail deer
[Music]
you know don't this will be the greatest
video we've ever made nailed it I can't
believe you're on your first deer call
Caroline father's teaching their sons to
hunt as a rite of passage as old as time
I always consider myself more of a
Marriott guy the Sun when you see your
first white-tailed deer it's gonna look
all cute and fluffy we can honor the
deer but we can't love it this is boy
turkey panini paninis are good bumps on
the deer what dear
[Music]
you know why I love these woods out here
there's nothing to disturb me amen when
you find a deer everything just falls
into place I can't believe this moment
is here at the shop
he doesn't take dawn now he may never
[Music]
why are you recording this dawn this is
part of the narrative I just figured it
might make a good midpoint crisis to
raise the stakes of the camera off dawn
trying to have a moment with my son
right mom and Greg said that I could
calm down
you called Greg dad yeah but only like
five times first time I met my
girlfriend she's like I'm a certified
mechanic an registered nurse no my go
yeah well guess what I got busted truck
in a heart condition
you and me have done things the wall is
going to remember I think you should
probably cover most of this stuff from
the other side of the bridge there you
want me to cross the bridge first so I
get coverage of you testing out the
bridge before anybody crosses it because
of some safe exactly don't worry I got
oh Jesus
you
you